madame monsieur bonsoir le dakar 96 a
été endeuillée aujourd'hui par la mort
de laurent guéguen le pilote d'un camion
mercedes qui a semble-t-il sauté sur une
mine datant de la guerre opposant
l'armée marocaine au front polisario
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
laurent frédéric bollée filles du repos
une fumée en plein désert
une fumée noire une fumée qui annonce
quelque chose de punaises
km 157 de la cinquième spéciale le
camion numéro 4 113 étend peu à son bord
se trouvaient trois hommes pascal renaud
vincent bodin et laurent guéguen
ce dernier est resté bloqué à bord du
camion il est officiellement déclarée
décédée cet après midi à 15 heures sur
les lieux même une sorte d' impact est
visible le camion a peut être sauté sur
une mine
c'est possible dans cette région
marocaine politiquement sensible plus la
présence non loin du front polisario
le camion d'assistance citroën est en
tout cas hors piste c'est là que réside
peut-être la clé de l'accident chez
citroën
c'est la désolation et énormément de
peine à croire que j'ai énormément de
peine
laurent guéguen avait 27 ans il était
marié et père d'une petite fille
pour les organisateurs du rallye toutes
les précautions de balisage avaient été
prises
si on avait le moindre doute si on avait
pensé qu'il y avait un risque quelconque
d'abord on aurait envoyé personne sur
cette piste
ensuite vous savez qu'il ya une
ouverture qui est en place c'est la
course
environ 3 4 jours avant le passage de la
ils nous ont rien noté d'anormal et donc
pour nous on a pris toutes les mesures
toutes les précautions nécessaires
autres faits terribles du jour cet
accident survenu à bruno saby
tonneau en séries pour la mitsubishi
mais les deux hommes sont indemnes
bruno saby a en tout cas course perdue
même s'ils tendent toujours apparemment
de réparer pour ramener sa voiture à
smara
quant au moteur français trou ça il
connaît la frayeur de sa vie dans cette
même spéciale
là aussi une chute épouvantable mais les
secours arrivent vite et là on peut
vraiment dire plus de peur que de mal ce
qui n'est pas le cas d'un autre motard
thierry rannou qui a été ramené ce soir
au bivouac dans le coma oui une journée
affreuse sur le dakar